[Applaudissements]
alors bonjour à tous j'ai pas de
présentation pour ma part je vous
raconte ma vie et je n'avais pas envie
de voir des photos de moi mais regarde
et je crois que je parle j'ai décidé de
garder ça assez simple je m'appelle
marie pierre et j'ai 28 ans puis j'ai 28
ans je vous en parle c'est pour moi
c'est vraiment important
ça a été mon premier sur price part j'ai
été vraiment surpris
mais surtout ça a été la première fois
qu'elle m'a fait les gens pleurer puis
ça c'est quelque chose aussi qui m'a pas
surpris mais qui m'a beaucoup touché je
comprendrais que quand je suis né mes
parents se sont fait dire que 28 ans
c'était mon espérance de vie
donc mes parents à ma fête était
évidemment très touché les amis à qui
j'avais partagé cette nouvelle était
aussi et c'est pour ça qu'ils m'avaient
organiser cette fête là et tout ça c'est
parce que quand je suis né on m'a
diagnostiqué avec la fibrose kystique
on me dit qu hec y avait des français
parfois donc pour l'heure la population
française de la salle lachowski stx et
la mucoviscidose et la fibrose kystique
vous en avez peut-être déjà entendu
parler il ya un film qui est sorti au
cinéma hier à ce sujet quand même un bon
timing
je vous invite à aller le voir pour
l'instant je n'ai pas de commentaire à
ce sujet je pense pas que c'est très
nécessaire man le plus représentatif
mais ça peut être intéressant de voir ce
que hollywood à en dire mais peut-être
que vous en avez peur dont tu parles et
non plus parce que la finance qui stx
une maladie rare c'est officiellement
une maladie rare au canada on et 4300
personnes atteintes fille au québec en
2017 on était 1219 personnes atteintes
de fibrose kystique donc la finance qui
sait ce que c'est je vais vous raconter
commun gratuitement ce maladie
dégénérative génétique mortelle pour
lequel existe à ce moment si aucun
traitement curatif et cette maladie qui
affecte principalement les systèmes
digestifs et les pour les poumons pour
les personnes atteintes sont constamment
bombardés de bactéries c'est un milieu
dans lequel les bactéries sont partis
il ya rarement confortable et ont envie
de se reproduire et de rester à vie par
exemple les bactéries qui colonisent les
piments qui s'appelle pseudomonas et que
j'ai depuis l'âge de 16 ans et dont on
n'arrive pas à se débarrasser les effets
pulmonaire de la fibrose kystique font
en sorte que la majorité des patients
vont à un point ou un autre de leur vie
devoir recevoir un don une greffe
pulmonaire et que ultime ans même après
cette greffe pulmonaire
les patients atteints vont
éventuellement mourir en raison de
complications liées à des infections au
point mais la finance critiques ce n'est
pas juste ça te soucies le système
digestif comme je disais donc il ya 85 %
des gens avec la finance et qui ne
peuvent pas digérer la nourriture et qui
doivent prendre les enzymes
pancréatiques pour pouvoir et se nourrir
il ya vingt-deux pourtant les gens avec
la fibrose kystique qui vont développer
qu'ils vont développer pardon un certain
type de diabète donc un diabète mx1 et
type 2 mais un diamètre qu'on appelle
liés à la fibrose kystique et donc ça
c'est pour le système digestif mais
encore une fois ce n'est pas tout la
fibrose kystique
si vous vous imaginez un petit diagramme
avec une personne comme moi ici et les
flèches des endroits qui sont touchés
par la finance critique il ya des
flèches absolument partout autour de moi
depuis que je suis né j'ai eu trois
opérations de pour les sinus 1 pour le
niveau 1 au niveau digestif et il ya des
problèmes au niveau évidemment de la
respiration notre peau est salée j'ai
même appris récemment que l'on pouvait
faire des réactions allergiques à l'eau
c'est très intéressant vous imaginerez
et donc moi quand j'expose mais pontdemé
trop longtemps à l'eau chaude
ça fait des réactions ça devient tout
plaquer et la pousse enlève et donc je
ne peux plus faire la vaisselle
malheureusement des pistes et la finance
critique fait donc quelque chose qui
touche tout tout le temps et moi même
j'en apprends tous les jours à force de
me demander pourquoi je me sens comme ça
de faire quelques recherches j'ai parlé
à mes médecins et de découvrir de
nouveaux symptômes
pour moi personnellement la finance
éthique ça veut aussi dire autre chose
savaient de 30 pilules par jour en
moyenne depuis que je suis née ça veut
dire 140 me à l'hôpital depuis que j'ai
eu
16 ans où j'étais gardé pour des
traitements intraveineux 85 jours de
traitement intraveineux à la maison dans
les trois dernières amis parce que j'ai
eu la chance de pouvoir les faire chez
moi de ne pas devoir rester à l'hôpital
des rendez vous chez les spécialistes ne
me le gastro-entérologue ou un réel pisi
collègues et aux deux semaines
si on les met tous ensemble et donc
c'est pas quelque chose que j'aime
particulièrement pour en gros la finance
que c'est nul
j'ai toujours su que j'étais
complètement nul parce que quand j'avais
4 ans que je suis à la garderie puis que
je prenne mes médicaments jeux l'amitié
d'une voix qui m'a dit mark r moi j'ai
su que même s'il prenait toujours tes
médicaments
ma maman m'a dit que tu allais mourir
pareil alors vous comprendrez que ma
mère n'était pas particulièrement
impressionné par la gestion ce moment et
à la maison et me demander comment je me
sentais et parent je dis bah je sais pas
ce que c'est vrai puis maman mehdi ben
oui c'est vrai stocker mais ce que ça va
arriver piétons à dissiper non vraiment
pas on fait tout ce qu'on a à faire pour
que ça n'arrive pas bientôt à ok mais
tant mieux parce que j'ai vraiment
beaucoup de choses à faire avoir et
c'est ce qu'on me disait que j'avais
raconté dans j'avais 4 ans mon slip mais
ça ne m'étonne pas du tout parce que
c'est un peu la maxime qui est contrôlé
ma vie par la suite
donc j'ai tout fait ce que j'avais à
faire pour moi j'étais un peu en mode
j'ai pas le temps d'aisé je dois tout
faire tout faire parfaitement parce que
j'aurais pas le temps de recommencer
ne pas faire d'erreur et donc je suis
allé à l'école chalot seconde âge me
s'impliquer dans tous les comités
j'ai gagné la médaille du lieutenant
gouverneur pour mon bénévolat en
suggérant trop cgt nantes ou encore tous
les comités à l'université associations
étudiantes
concours de plaidoirie on en a marre ras
j'ai décidé aussi de faire un double bac
parce que c'était passé fallait que ça
aille plus vite et ça à culminée un peu
dans ma troisième année d'un verset
quand j'ai décidé que en plus de mes co
2 double balle vous allez créer un poste
additionnels dans l'association
étudiante pour gérer les gens qui
étaient en double bac et j'allais aussi
participé à ce concours de plaidoirie où
on s'est rendu à la finale nationale
évidemment et ensuite dit ça j'allais
aussi faire la course aux stages la
course aux stars dans le milieu du droit
ce qui peut se faire qu'à l'entrée vous
sont familiers avec ce processus là mais
c'est un truc un peu loufoque où pendant
trois semaines se mettent à vie en rose
et tu fais toutes sortes d'entrevue qui
sont à montréal pour la plupart alors
que moi j'ai utilisé à ottawa et donc tu
prends le train le bus anigo express du
train at ease entrevue et ça se passe
toujours à peu près pendant les examens
ni cession j'explique vraiment le moment
génial et donc j'ai commencé sa très
confiante et je suis évidemment tomber
malade ce qui s'est passé c'est que j'ai
commencé pendant une première entrevue à
faire la fièvre que je me suis dit bon
je pense que c'est que gbl pas et j'ai
commencé à me sentir très mal
puis en fait s'est produit c'est que je
pense juste vraiment tombé très malade
et j'ai quand même continué processus
ça plus un simple je le dis donc le ca
va vraiment que je retiens et qui parce
que quand je disais ça s'appelait dire
que ça allait vraiment pas ça vaut
vraiment pas mais j'ai un dernier souper
la semaine prochaine mercredi qui est la
troisième entrevue faut que je me rende
leur par la suite vous ferez ce que vous
voulez mais l'a pour l'instant faut que
je me rende à ce souper et donc je me
rendais à c'est super puis c'est le
fameux vraiment frappé c'est l'objet en
plus de toucher le fond parce que
j'avais loué une chambre d'hôtel à
montréal j'étais à tabac et j'ai passé
le lundi mardi mercredi de cette semaine
là où il y avait les cocktails et des
super le soir dans la chambre d'hôtel à
faire la fièvre a essayé de dormir avant
la difficulté à tenir debout assez
longtemps pour me laver les cheveux mais
la monf est quand même et être sorti de
ma chambre d'hôtel pour pouvoir aller à
mon cocktail mais j'ai marché en place
sans doute l ascenseur de l'hôtel
fallait que je prenne une pause en
espèce de gros sous feu vert de
corridors de chambre d'hôtel un bon cinq
minutes pour reprendre son souffle et me
rends à l'ascenseur je suis à l'âme au
coktail jet miraculeusement passe à
travers lequel souvenir de ce cocktail
et mais je n'ai pas de regret je
soutiens et par la suite le lendemain
les animaux ramenés à la maison ma mère
m'attendait avec une valise l'hôpital
m'attendait avec une chambre je suis
arrivé et ce qu'on m'a dit c'est que mes
poumons fonctionner à 25% de la capacité
j'avais besoin d'oxygène immédiat puis
pas une canule un masque d'oxygène et
j'ai été trois semaines à l'hôpital par
la suite par contre à ce moment là mon
cerveau pas non plus encore compris je
vous dirais je disais non à celles qui
vont faire les gros yeux on s'avoue pas
tout à fait encore à ce jour compris que
des fois fallait que je fasse plus
attention mais je travaille et à ce
moment là j'étais assise à l'hôpital
puis j'attendais mon offre il n'y avait
pas d'histoire des roches malades vrai
que je prenne soin noirs lançaient est
ce que mon téléphone va sonner
est-ce que je vais avoir une oeuvre
qu'est ce que je vais réussir s'est
plaint que je me suis donc je sais pas
si depuis que je vis par vous avez une
petite idée du type de personnalité que
j'ai je dirais que c'est un peu tard et
un peu contrôlant un peu organisés et
donc j'avais ce plat que jamais été
formulée que jamais été écrit mais mon
plan c'était clairement de dire à la
chemise kystique une mort aux pommes je
vais tout faire que je veux faire quand
même
et j'ai pas besoin de toi dans ma vie
donc au revoir et j'ai ignoré la chemise
kystique
pour la majeure partie de ma vie en
prenant soin de moi autant que j'aurais
dû le faire évidemment j'ai pris des
médicaments j'ai fait mes traitements
j'ai été à l'hôpital mais j'ai pas fait
tout ce que j'aurais pu faire pour ma
santé
parce que c'était vraiment un problème
and noise ça nous dérange est à faire le
jeu l'est pas y penser et donc les
seules fois où je m'arrêtais à cosa
france kystique ça en des moments comme
je viens de vous décrire où j'étais
vraiment au bout où je pouvais plus puis
où on forcer à le faire et ça ça a
continué pendant plusieurs années
donc à chaque fois une session après un
événement important comme ça à chaque
noël
chaque été je tombais malade je prenais
deux semaines personne ne savait
vraiment parce que les obligations était
terminée puis par la suite j'ai
recommencé
je conseille comme ça j'ai fait mon bar
ont d'ailleurs un peu moins de temps que
ce qui a été mentionné dans las lines
préférant un but tout prix et par la
suite chalet à paris faire ma maîtrise à
la sorbonne en droit comparé et puis
survenu pour faire mon stage dans le
grand bureau qui m'a fait une offre
alors que j'étais sur mon lit d'hôpital
le vendredi matin après le cac perd et
dans ses bureaux là j'ai commencé le
stage avec cette idée que je savais très
bien que dans un grand bureau comme
borderlands gervais où je travaille
encore à présentement la vie est pas
fait pour être accommodées
nécessairement si un environnement de
haute performance c'est un environnement
où les attentes sont extrêmement élevés
et où les jeunes travaille extrêmement
fort pour se rendre à s'adapter de grade
par le chip éventuellement c'est un peu
le chemin qu'on nous donne mais moi même
si je refusais de voir que la fibrose
kystique m'empêchera pas quoi que ce
soit c'est quand même un peu réaliste
puis jamais rêvé d'être une peur nous
parce qu'on s'attaque à 28 ans on est
pas parvenu
puis moi je dis pas que j'attendais
d'avoir 28 ans pour tomber mourir mais
la vie au delà de 28 ans était pas
vraiment envisagé dont je me disais j'ai
fait plus que je peux j'ai donné un bon
un an deux ans au maximum
puis après on verra pas grave mais ce
que j'ai fait pendant deux ans je leur
ai fait mon meilleur de mes capacités
puis je pourrais on pourra pas de dire
que la fibrose kystique égales et que
j'avais cette idée lost plan le et long
je rentrais pour faire mon stage 6 mois
de stage avant de devenir avocate
et au bout de quatre mois de stage et de
manque de sommeil et de sorties avec les
collègues et de prendre soin de moi mais
je tombais malade mais c'était pas du
tout aux plans d'un petit j'arrivais à
me rendre à la fin de la session
j'arrivais à me rendre à fin de l'examen
les manquer de moi tu es médecin me
disais que j'arrivais pas à me rendre
mon corps me disais que j'arrivais pas à
me rendre donc j'ai pas eu le choix que
d'aller voir maman ta fille lui
expliquer qu'il fallait que je prenne
une pause
le pour moi ça voulait dire que j'avais
pardon que j'avais raté j'avais raté mon
plan j'ai tout raté ma vie ne servait à
rien je me rendrai pas au bout parce que
j'avais dit que je ferais
j'étais convaincu j'aurais pas d'offres
d'emploi par la suite à cause de cette
semaine là où j'ai pas été travail et ça
je pense que évidemment c'était pas très
rationnel mais en même temps c'est un
peu le sentiment auquel on était puis je
pense qu'on peut tous se sentir un peu
comme ça parfois quand on est dans un
environnement qui demande autant de
performances qui autant de don de soi
d'avoir l'impression qu'elle a plus
petites choses pourraient tous contre m
j'étais maman maman tard au lieu de me
dire bon mais zones moins bien médical
par une vie en vert jeudi je peux bien
médical mais j'aimerais vraiment se
rencontrer ton médecin
pourquoi je le connais ces grecs sinon
mais j'aimerais ça c'est qu'on s'assoit
puis quand on regarde ce qu'on peut
faire pour que ça marche mais quoi ça
marche ça marche
à ce moment tout va bien il n'y a pas de
problème n'est pas de problème je perds
ton temps à venir il y en aura pas de
problème j'ai dit non mais c'est
vraiment l'fun puis on va mais notre
buzz puis on veut son assassin on veut
trouver des façons que tu peux te rester
sur le long terme avec nous parce
qu'elle est a commencé à comprendre que
j'allais me brûler c'est ça qu'on a fait
puis c'est ça qui m'a forcé un petit peu
a commencé à parler de la fibrose
kystique
il a donc mis en gage parler de la
fibrose kystique parce que c'est quelque
chose que je maîtrisais que je
connaissais les statistiques que je vous
ai mentionné de parachever connaît
depuis toujours j'ai été porte parole
j'étais tête d'affiche pour pour
l'association canadienne de la fibrose
kystique
mais je me concentre je me contentais de
mentionner des statistiques de
mentionner les schistes que je disais
puis pseudomonas 15e pancréatiques puis
fonction pulmonaire
c'est des mots que je pouvais dire
régulièrement je les applique est jamais
à ma situation
jusqu'à il ya deux ans mes meilleurs
amis et même mes parents ne
connaissaient pas le chiffre de ma
fonction pulmonaire ce à dire qu'on
donne un pourcentage de pour quelqu'un
de ma time emploi et mon âge qui dont
les fonctions dont les poumons pardon
fonctionne parfaitement
les poumons de cette personne serait
donc à 100% moi mes poumons sont à
croquer quand j'étais jeune et à 90%
quand je rentrais à l'université j'ai
commencé à avoir un plateau par 60% que
j'arrivais pas à remonter
aujourd'hui je vous dirais que je sais
entre les 40 et 50 % quand les choses
vont bien mais ça c'est des chiffres qui
me faisait extrêmement peur et dont je
parlais à personne
plus ils commençaient à travers donc ici
je parle de fonctions pulmonaires
grosjean va probablement falloir que je
que je leur explique que moi sa
formation
puis les gens vont commencer à
comprendre que je respire exactement
deux fois moins bien qu'eux puis quand
je monte les escaliers bien
effectivement je souffrais à la fin puis
c'est les choses que les gens commencent
à comprendre c'est une chose qui me
faisait extrêmement peur en même temps
j'ai commencé à essayer
j'ai commencé avec la coiffeuse genre ah
oui belge et la france qui s'épuise
mais d'habitude j'aurais dit non mais ça
va vraiment bien je prends des
médicaments et et c'est sous contrôle je
suis très stable tout laisse contre je
sais pas j'ai pas cette semaine j'ai
monté jusqu'à livre ça a été vraiment
d'ici là concept h contre a tellement
tellement désolée pour toi que la
réponse était très positif plus j'en ai
parlé à ma massothérapeute je faisais je
suis très mal au dos ou oui c'est la
posture le stress mais en réalité aussi
tous beaucoup
souvent je me réveille la nuit pour tous
et je pense que ça pourrait avoir des
tensions
ben oui tout à fait qu'elle change son
plan de traitement pour pour justement
ciblées c'est en cela que j'ai commencé
à réaliser qu'en fait en en parlant de
cette façon le et non en 10 ans quel
point j'étais forte tout le temps
puisque c'est pas grave mais ça a amené
quelque chose de quand même positif et
c'est à ce moment là aussi qu'au bureau
on a mis en place les mesures
d'accompagnement j'étais extrêmement
française parce que je tombe sur un
cabinet qui m'a pris sous son ère qui a
décidé que ça allait fonctionner et donc
au bout de mon stage au lieu de ne pas
me faire d'offres d'emploi on me fait
une offre emploi conditionnelle à ce que
moi j'accepte les mesures
d'accommodement qui me serait imposée
parce que ça vous donne une idée
il m'avait bien cerner c'est exactement
ce qui s'est passé et j'ai accepté de
façon très lente
j'essaie de mes gosses ils mesurent la
commandement bond on veut
retravailler sa force intérieure
facturables des bureaux d'avocats fait
votre travail tant d'heures donc deux
cents de moins que cinq cents de moins
que tes collègues
nous allons non non non mais je 200 - ça
met en place je serais capable
non mon ami tant d'années - au nombre la
première année j'ai tenu mon bout et
évidemment qu'est ce qui s'est passé je
suis tombé malade mais ils m'ont dit on
mais peut-être qu'on veut baisser encore
ses frais que tu acceptes puis au pire
par un peu plus pas grave et que ça a
été vraiment difficile pour moi de
l'accepter même temps avec des gens qui
vous poussait qui autour de moi les gens
si j'ai commencé à m'ouvrir le meilleur
ami mon copain qui fait aujourd'hui
qu'ils ont commencé à me poser des
questions auxquelles d'habitude je
répondais pas où j'ai vite et plus les
vraies questions
les vrir discussion c'est devenu que
même un super de sa mort ou est-ce qu'on
parlait de nos problèmes de job de nos
relations plus difficile mais ça
devenait un sujet comme ça où est ce que
bon souper bon vin quelques larmes
on en parle c'est correct qui ont un
support
si quelque chose à quoi je m'attendais
vraiment puis à partir de ce moment là
aussi on a commencé à me demander de
parler à des événements comme
aujourd'hui par exemple mais aussi de
faire un article dans un journal en
droit notamment de parler à certains
événements de levée de fonds également
ou auprès d'autorités gouvernementales
que ça me force à réfléchir je me suis
dit mon discours d'habitude deux je suis
forte capable je me relève
je ne trouve pas approprié parce que ça
me pas servir dans la vie d'un être
forte puis de me relever
ça m'a servi pour me rendre où je suis
je le regrette pas mais ses postures qui
fait qui je suis parce que ça j'ai pas
le choix de le faire le combat qu'on
m'attribue gelé peu choisis j'ai pas le
choix si je me relève le lendemain c'est
parce que j'ai pas le choix
mais si je décide que c'est là que ça
devient un peu quétaine mais en même
temps c'est ce qui est ressorti de ma
réflexion
si je décide que ce dont j'ai tellement
peur tu as de la vulnérabilité qui à
l'intérieur de moi je n'accepte pas
rendu là mais j'essaie je les accepte
puis j'en parle d'une façon très ouvert
mais en réalité ce qui se passe c'est
que du positif
c'est du positif au travail pour moi
aussi pour le travail les attentes sont
gérés en conséquence une des maisons de
commandement qu'on a mis en place au
travail c'est que les mercredis je
travaille de la maison comme ça si je me
sens pas bien il n'y a pas de pression
comme ça c'est le genre rendez vous à
prendre chez un spécialiste seuls 30
mercredi puis ça maintenant mes
collègues de travail le mardi 10 à jeudi
c'est aussi simple que ça alors qu'au
début ça me faisait paniquer je me
disais que je n'aurai pas de dossier
intéressant que je me ferais pas une
garderie pas ou des choses comme ça j'ai
réalisé qu'en fait tout le monde était
gagnant danser dans ce milieu locke dans
ce genre d'accommodement le même avec
mes amis ma famille on s'est rapprochés
parce qu'on a pu avoir ces discussions
le puits pour la communauté fibrose
kystique à travers le canada mais pour
la communauté au sujet des personnes qui
ont un qui sont atteints de certains
problèmes de santé quels qu'ils soient
où d'autres genres de problèmes de voir
que cette vulnérabilité là ça peut
apporter quelque chose de positif
au lieu devant la cacher surtout leur
espèce de monde hyper performant où on
est puis de voir et de comprendre que
vulnérabilité puis ce succès c'est pas
incompatibles moi personnellement ça a
changé ma vie je pense que ça peut
changer celle de l'autre personne aussi
puis quand je pense à se plaint que je
m'étais mis en tête
j'ai pas eu le choix de le remettre en
question le mot prochaine ça va faire
deux ans que je t'avoue catch et bruno
gervais je prévois restent elles encore
de nombreuses familles donc je pensais
pour moi s'est plaint le y est plus
valide et que en ayant osé est
vulnérable
je pense qu'on peut faire de grandes
choses merci
[Applaudissements]